you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution i used to work i
used to volunteer at a wildlife
rehabilitation center and so we would
deal with you know injured
birds of all kind injured mammals
pretty much anything we weren't allowed
to work with wolves or deer or
possums because possums were considered
nuisance and coyotes were considered
nuisance and then wolves and deer were
just too big for us but we we dealt with
pretty much everything else in the state
of oregon
we had an osprey come in who didn't that
didn't make it
on screen right now i'm showing some
photos by this guy on instagram his name
is joinus12345
but his real name is chen jiangwang he
does these amazing osprey photos where
he'll take a bunch of pictures as
they're hitting the water
we had an osprey come in who didn't that
didn't make it
and
the guy that i was working with the guy
who runs the place he was showing me it
it had a broken
humerus this is the humerus right yeah
had a broken humerus so the upper arm
bone and he was showing me that's got
these little uh it's a very hollow bone
but it has these they look like bicycle
spikes yeah these struts that go across
he was telling me that those form
according to how that individual happens
to hit the water when it's hunting so
those spokes will change over time he
says that every time he looks at one
it's it's slightly different and
he thinks that it's it's remodeling i
don't know if if that sounds like a
legitimate
hypothesis to you i mean it does it does
in a way where um
i would not be surprised especially
early on in the animal's life so so
bird bones in general are quite hollow
uh pterosaurs are the same way and they
have struts um
to kind of prop up the inside of the
bone and distribute the pressure without
not without adding extra weight
because you know one way to make your
bones strong is just to make them thick
but if you really want to get um air
bound you're not gonna want to add all
that weight so the way they do it is
they add all these struts
now it's interesting because there is a
couple of studies that show okay like
here's an ulna of a vulture and we know
the way vultures hold their wings
because you know they kind of soar and
they do it one way and there isn't a
whole lot of external differences in
pressure and so they scanned these bones
and they saw that yeah okay the struts
are you know uh placed in areas of high
pressure because we can actually test
possibly where pressure is uh based on
the bone shape so i don't think that's a
crazy hypothesis i wonder how much of it
does change because
as as you're remodeling something you're
taking stuff away and you're adding so
you have to
do it at a rate that isn't weakening the
bone right so the way we have
osteoporosis is that the remodeling is
happening so fast that you're doing a
lot of the taking away without doing a
lot of the adding
so i would assume this would be a
problem for diving birds where you know
their remodeling just has to be at a
good enough pace
um
i think he was saying
it's been a long time since i had this
conversation with him but i think he was
saying that the juveniles have more than
the adult so it's like the juveniles
have them all over the place randomly
and the adults have them only in
specific positions according to how
they've been hunting
i would not be surprised that would
totally make sense to me i mean yeah if
the juveniles kind of went
all out with making struts at the
beginning and then the biology kind of
like biology of the bone kind of narrows
it down and takes away the ones that are
not useful and that actually happens in
us as well so um the our ephemeral like
the top of the femur where it hits or
inserts into the hip it has all these
struts
that are
optimized for our type of walking
and it distributes the the pressure well
from you know hitting into the hip and
also back into the femur so you know so
you don't snap off your
uh femoral head which is a really bad
injury so it's it's a yeah so it's a
good way to distribute that so we have
all these struts too and they've shown
that yeah okay the struts and runners
look different than the struts and you
know your average joe that just maybe
walks to work
um
so we look different on the inside
depending on what we're doing and those
definitely remodel over our lifetime so
that's so neat well that's it for this
clip but don't worry i post clips
regularly and every thursday i post
completely fresh content make sure
you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome